yeah I played flute for like three years
do you put up your cap what has been
your most favorite prank that you have
pulled oh my you might as well put it
into the beginning of the tape that's
what happened if he's off camera she was
talking we were talking about eighth
grade graduation and how give it too
much context well you didn't have it
it's better without the contact okay
fine she cause she just asked me if I
ever put a flute flute up my [ __ ] and
then it because she's so far away that
is not the context flautists sir flashes
and then Nikki asked if you ever put a
flute up your [ __ ] and she didn't
register because I couldn't hear her and
then it's like that happened and that's
what you guys walked in on saw that and
then it hit me if I put a flute in my
[ __ ] so I'm like oh [ __ ] I got a lot of
House Bunny
so you have the answer oh [ __ ] just
kidding it was a rented food okay [ __ ] a
rented food [ __ ] me no it's just least
it was like $40 a month until I owned it
and then at the end I owned it did you
put it up there did you put it up no
it's just that American Pie came out
during that year like while I was a
flautist and so it was like that's
really what is called the fattest yes
but I heard so back in the Mozart days
they tried to call them flutist but
nobody could say without laughing
they kept pianists flautist units
flautist wise they're all in there it
should be a flute er hey you oh that's
lau TISS pianist is the worst one
that's a tough one man the movie was
great though named suck the poster
sucked too it's just a guy city of piano
what's happening in the in the movie
anyway I saw him at the paint store one
time yeah a paint store Sherwin Williams
Sherman Williams no we were at the oh
you know what it is it's not a paint so
it's a craft store we're at Michael
Michael and I saw him there versions I
wanted him to be like crafting something
a little funnier no I think he's getting
a frame or something maybe the people
who invented these titles were plan a
prank huh hot if yeah they're playing a
prank
there we go circling your back so funny
I was but yeah cuz I know I know you
play pranks on your kids don't ya I've
never got them I've never succeeded that
though I wanted to do the one I hope you
guys saw the dad he put something like a
spaghetti noodle his mouth well then it
cracked and then I tried to of my kids
and they're just like what are you
eating something well what's in your
mouth you do it way delayed you're like
yeah it was terrible and in the video I
just was eating it after a while cuz I
was a little hungry when I did the prank
- yeah I forgot it was it's mostly a
fail it's obviously a better prank than
half of the pranks I've ever watched in
the past two years really yeah it's big
it's gotten roughest Oh YouTube friends
the worst acting ever yeah well I have a
story here about a 65 year old man from
Belgium who has he has been getting
pranked for the last nine years and he's
just [ __ ] sick and tired of it after
nine years he barely the same breaker or
multiple prank that's dedication guy
stuff okay so he still doesn't know
who's pranking him over the last nine
years someone has been sending pizza and
other food deliveries to his home and so
constantly for the last nine years he's
been having to reject
someone that used to live there and I
keep accidentally ordering postmates
nine years that's a blessing like I've
done it four times in a row by accident
by address okay so I will order on the
way home from recording at the podcast
studio and I've ordered somebody else
does that
my friends got it and they say that I'm
fast but but you do it too yeah because
it takes so long it's efficient time I
get home I still got 20 minutes to wait
but it's not a great idea to have your
old address still in the app but so the
podcast address is in there and it just
automatically assumes that I'm want the
food delivered there and I don't check
to make sure it's at my home address so
maybe the person is like it just is
login ahead nine years ago they didn't
have postman's yes they call me back for
that cuz I used to time my food to meet
me at home I don't know why that's
that's a fish I don't want to drop those
friends it's to here so he's wondering
well he should he should find other
reasons to call you that
maybe also order from two different post
mates at once there's nothing wrong with
that either so have week I'm talking
about that
well you can't like have them make
multiple stops so you can not have to
pull up and get the ice cream on your
way i'd be easy sure he's kind of fat
but sure nope we're kind of the whole
idea of post mates is kind of fact
that's true like cook my food and bring
it to me separate entities yes and i
love the nude like drop it off at the
door i don't want to talk are you okay
with this come on okay with this I do
say thanks through like our net like our
ringer thing I'm like thank you I pick
out the door watch them walk away and
when they leave them like I say thank
you for my balcony down to that
thank you so you gotta go all the way
you see them coming through the hole
just to be the king that's a that's a
definite big kind of sitting position
hands on the hips is I'm better than you
for sure is he vegetarian and they keep
sending him meat or something that's a
good question I don't know that but I do
know that they have been having
deliveries go to his home even like in
the middle of the night like at 2:00
a.m. what the [ __ ] is open because maybe
they're like we shall send that old man
some food no so the thing is the reason
why he knows that someone deliberately
[ __ ] with him is because he also has
a friend in a different city a woman
that she it started at the same time for
her too so for the last nine years she
has also endured all it's that girl
she's trying to flirt with him she's
like me too something to bond with him
on he stalks her for nine years because
of it that could make sense because he
does mention that like sometimes she'll
get a food delivery first and then
she'll hit him up and say like hey just
a heads up did you get one you're about
to get one and then you'll get one I
don't think so this guy's like there's
guys like I don't get it do people send
me [ __ ] through delivers all the time
somebody's been paying my mortgage for
ten days wash my car get my mail for me
the foods not poison it's just like good
food to eat hot food or if it's his
favorite food I was in the mood for
blueberry pie and it's blueberry pie I
[Music]
only told my friend I'm in the mood for
blueberry pie just came her - nine years
ago there was no coach man a really
committee years ago just pizza in
Chinese food you can get he's got a
prank about face
I thought about it I'm like you must
have pissed someone off you know people
love to look at pictures of like Obama
and stuff and they go like oh man the
weight of the office really weathered
him this guy's like all these years of
Pizza change my face enjoyed it they
would be like oh it's not fun anymore
it's true no I mean it's crazy because
he says that one day in one day I
January 2019 he received no less than 10
different food deliveries one of which
was for 14 pizzas I like I called a
journalist about this too like hey
you're gonna do a story on me getting
this free food that would be annoying
though yes getting 14 foot delivery is
like there's no way to be hungry then I
know who it is though because there's
gotta be somebody in his life is like
even eating good yeah cuz you gotta like
see that prank for it to be worth it
yeah yeah that's what he thinks it's one
of like him and the girls like mutual
friends and I'm like I'm pretty sure you
can narrow it down like how many [ __ ]
you people really know but he said that
one day that one day that all those ten
delivery showed up it cost 450 euros for
the mess like like some method oh well
he is not the parent that's the thing
where he was like this prank is more on
pranks restaurants because they actually
end up throwing the food away lots of
the times and he doesn't have to pay
since he's never receiving the food so
it's mainly a prank on all these food
places I thought they're paying for I
know they're paying for it - no they're
not post-meeting it no wait why is the
restaurant delivering food that's not
paid for
that's Belgium for you all he's in bed
need to change their systems yeah
dude so this poor cat boy came and order
anything because they're all like nah
man that's what I was thinking - I'm
like if if this has been happening for
just even like six months I would call
every single restaurant and be like
listen I'm gonna give you a code word
this code word is said then you know
it's me any other food deliveries to
this address just ignore them
that's a good solution to clawing every
restaurant in the area I'm talking about
the codeword idea Belle just big yo I
don't know I mean especially in this
town who knows I don't know Belgium so
big it has a [ __ ] city inside of a
call from Flyers that ever you come up
with the solution Steve she's just
winging it
I know but I do you know a buff on the
hole and it has a little error and it's
won't work no I would rather put that
work in than nine years of this [ __ ] I
would move you move out of Belgium ya
know what if this was like a family on
like four centrum home which was your
dream home let me shoot a [ __ ] not
provide a solution can I borrow it
[ __ ] love that I'm here to [ __ ] I
don't eat when tea former president I
leave this honest it's not they do
anything anyway shirt yeah let Steve
twenty pointy and then I'm just here to
[ __ ] not a free spirit I love it
yeah I don't know I mean nine years of
food that's just pretty sucks actually
yeah it's too much there's no
fulfillment what's the payoff its
meaning well I mean I guess whoever
whoever's in his life can see the path
because he says that he said I cannot
sleep anymore I start shaking every time
I hear a scooter on the street I dread
that someone will come to drop off hot
pizzas yet another time it's like that
water torture where it like just drips
but you know the drips are like
inconsistent but except it's pizza it's
at the top because it's delicious
can you work with the restaurant okay
will revert like star-69 this is phone
call don't they have caller ID like
caller ID like who's making these calls
or you could eat the pizza
[Music]